the joe rogan experience so this [ __ ]
dave chappelle thing's crazy uh last
night i guess it was someone attacked
him at the hollywood bowl he's fine
i checked in with him today he was
laughing about it he's uh in good
spirits he was there's a video actually
he was laughing like right afterwards
yeah because jamie foxx apparently had a
cowboy hat he jumped on stage to help
jimmy fox with a cowboy hat jumped on
stage to [ __ ] that dude up
the guy was uh
five foot that that arm's broken by the
way
definitely
that arm's [ __ ] there is also like the
way they led him into the um the like
when he got into the actual stretcher
you could see he's [ __ ] it's so funny
you can tell the type of beat up that
somebody is when they're getting kicked
on the ground by different from
different angles by different people
it's a different type of like
beat up look
yeah you can tell that that left that
that left side of his face was the side
that was either on the ground or totally
like away from everything yeah i was
getting punched just everything's
swollen on the one side yeah he's [ __ ]
that guy
see me jesus christ you could tell you
can always tell because the did you you
saw the actual video i saw the video
first of all dave chappelle has good
hips
because yeah he the guy she almost
sprawled on him and he kind of turned
with him he kind of conclude him yeah he
came a little like keto
if you watch the video as the guy's
coming in he's coming in this way and
dave kind of like turns a little it's
balls too chappelle's a big boy bigger
than you think he is
well the guy's crazy clearly there's
something wrong with him
look at this and i mean there's just no
way look at this describe how
not expecting that you are when you're
on stage yeah okay he just runs away
and then the comedian clicks in and he
comes back because he's like wait i have
to it's my mic right now look at this
guy running
oh my god that guy's never tackled
anybody in his life
no chappelle almost almost makes the
clear out all the way yeah almost if he
just had a little training see that was
all an instinct
if he just had a little training imagine
if he just punted that dude in the head
when he went down yeah one of those
mosfidel knees there is no
security in the front row at this thing
like there should have been someone
there that was uh scanning the audience
for [ __ ] weirdos they're ready to
sprint
crazy well we live in strange times man
i mean after the chris rock thing that
was one of the things i was worried
about i was like people are thinking
they're gonna start smacking comedians
now if they don't like what they're
saying
and what i'm thinking
or what i'm worried about
is uh you know people think that's
justified like people keep they keep
using the same things i saw an article
they said his transphobic statements
they're not [ __ ] statements they're
jokes they're not jokes that are
transphobic either they're jokes that
feature trans people they're not
transphobic jokes his whole bit in that
last special that everybody was mad at
is essentially a love letter to his
friend that killed herself because she
was supporting him and she got attacked
on stage
the idea that that in somehow or another
is transphobic just because he's talking
about a trans person is [ __ ] crazy
right it's and then they just don't want
to be talked about that's essentially
what it is like they're saying it's
transphobic if you're even
mentioning trans people as a subject
with his
bonkers yes because it's really the
opposite right that that means that
they're equal if you're being included
in an american free conversation and
obviously a comedy set
like that means that you're part of the
everything else you're now
yeah i mean
you we all of course everything's part
of the everything else but it's like if
there's stuff that you cannot discuss
at all because it's so hot the subject
can't be brought up well this is we this
is a nonsense way of communicating you
can't communicate like that right you
can't say people can't discuss topics
right or discuss something that is
prominent in culture right now i mean
there's a lot of discussions about
trans rights and about use of bathrooms
and about
you know trans kids and the white house
talks about it and jen saki was doing an
interview and she was crying about it
sort of misrepresenting what the don't
say
supposedly don't say gay bill in florida
which isn't don't say gay
you know this is uh it's a weird time
because we we have to be able to look
through the fog the fog of
the anger that we have for the opposite
or the anger we have for the opponent
because the way that
the democrats and the way the
republicans look at it today
is
there's us and there's them and it's so
polarized that anytime something comes
up anything like well these these
subjects like you want to find out what
side
is on what side of the issue like is is
my side on this is okay or is my side on
this is a bad thing